olá a todos
antes mas eu peço desculpa pela minha
voz mas eu espero que vocês consigam
ouvir mãe
a eu não trouxe ladsous propositadamente
porque eu estava ter uma conversa
convosco a descer a um pouco o nível
nacional
vocês não podem responder nesta qualquer
maneira
aqui vai o que eu vou querer fazer aqui
vai ser um para um beijo entre mim ea
minha boca pequena experiência
profissional ea empresa para a qual
trabalha na qual trabalho que é mais nem
menos mas eu estava a explicar os além
da indústria mostra trabalhamos que é
internet das coisas e para isso
precisava da nossa ajuda ã levanta não
quem aqui tem uns smartphones a equipe
aqui eu vivo num apartamento ou numa
casa expectativa e quem daqui têm
internet em casa
voa basicamente são os três ingredientes
essenciais para internet das coisas e
mais especificamente para a casa
inteligente ou smart on que aquilo em
que nós trabalhamos e portanto estas
coisas aqui é que aqui um filho sam em
objetos como uma lâmpada uma máquina de
lavar a louça máquina de lavar roupa uma
tomada que esteja que tenham em casa que
esteja conectada à internet está
conectado à internet significa que ao
contrário do que acontece hoje em dia
que nós todos interagem com a tomada
ligamos e desligamos manualmente não há
qualquer tipo de resposta o pelo fato de
estar ligado à internet
não só nós podemos interagir com este
objeto através do nosso mar de funk como
também podemos obter um certificado vêm
destes objetos para conosco obviamente
que uma vez que os smartphones vai
conosco para todo lado é hoje em dia que
o que está em começar a utilizar mais
para interagir
com estes dispositivos no entanto daqui
pra frente e aqui quase que esta casa
inteligente se torna invisível no
sentido em que se adaptar a nós maneira
que nós não temos quase que fazer nada
ah ah então isso para mostrar a partir
daqui que nós até agora tem um instinto
preocupado muito com a nossa casa está
na altura de nossa casa e se preocupar
conosco
a mim já aconteceu várias vezes cara
vocês também eu saio de casa e esqueço
das chaves dentro de casa
ou eu passar a ferro às vezes acontece a
e sai casar com ele portanto lembro eu
sei e ferro eu não sei e ferro ou de
gaia am o ferro do cabelo não e nas duas
uma ou o risco de se aliar a minha casa
ou então volta atrás e escalar volta
atrás foi perceber que realmente tinha
desligado
mas há uma coisa que da qual nunca me
esqueço que é o meu telemóvel é de
batatas maior no nosso telenovela
atitude que dizem que a partir do
smartphone as duas ficam mais 50 minutos
na casa de banho
portanto não é nova e realmente é um
objecto essencial na nossa vida e é
muito mais valioso do que nós imaginamos
isto para dizer que o produto que eu
estou a apresentar é uma aplicação que
permite integrar todos os dispositivos
como lâmpadas e aquecedores e é
completamente agnóstica marcas e todos
se aglomeram em uma só aplicação
portanto em vez de terem uma lâmpada em
uma aplicação um aquecedor e uma
aplicação para interagirem manualmente
com com ela tem apenas uma aplicação
para todos estes dispositivos
deixem darmos um cenário a estamos em
casa a o presente nós temos as nossas
plantas mais ou menos consoante aquilo
que chamo de olha vou jogar agora eu vou
jogar amanhã
sem nunca dar grande importância é a
melhor altura para atacar as nossas
plantas
ora se nós tivemos um sistema de rega
conectado e estivermos um sensor tanta
conectado
sei quando é que o atleta realmente
precisa da água e nós podemos apenas
ativar o sistema de rega quando neste
dia não choveu ea hora indicada o que
não só nos poupar água como nos ajuda
também é poupar dinheiro e portanto é
basicamente esse é o produto ou nós
estamos a trabalhar e eu em particular
estou a trabalhar em cima e quando
valley é fazer parcerias e o que são
essas parcerias
todas essas marcas com um philips insone
e outras que fabricam estes produtos
nossos nós queremos que os entregam os
produtos deles na nossa marca porque nós
criamos mais valor não só para o
consumidor mas também para a marca
porque aquilo que antigamente era apenas
uma lâmpada que liga e desliga of
facilmente uma plataforma como esta
tornar se á um alerta se o velho fumo em
casa por exemplo pode ajudar a pessoa a
simular presença cada vez que eu sair de
casa por 116 preso tempo posso criar um
cenário no meu telemóvel em que vê
indicação de que esta é aquela luz devem
ser acionados para simula simular a
presença em casa daí criei realmente eu
juntamente com os meus colegas como
trabalho consideramos que estamos em
inovar e consideramos essencial é nova a
nossa ideia era se liga vale a vocês
pensarem um pouco a nossa realidade é já
é complicado nós temos uma carta que
poucos recursos russos são é de mil
pessoas
a ad difícil conseguir financiamento
quase ninguém os conhece aí já é um
grande um grande problema que nós
enfrentamos assunto ponto e nós vamos
gostar tanto que está a trabalhar na
internet das coisas quem é que começa a
internet das coisas
eu e várias vezes falo com amigos meus e
e ea minha família e digo que faço e
toda a gente fica assim um caso lá em 3
antes disso nada mas é muito muito
sangue e portanto essa sensibilização
que existe é impessoal e na europa e
mesmo
os estados unidos não é gigantesca não
existe realmente um mercado emergente
que está a crescer muito
isso quer dizer que voltando atrás somos
uma torta já é complicado mostrar tanto
a trabalhar na internet as coisas ainda
mais complicado mas ter tanta oferta
portuguesa é trabalhar nos estados
unidos é completamente avassalador
porque primeiro muitas vezes a reforma
do yuan ao está feliz mas completamente
as importantes não só somos pequenos
como ainda somos mais pequenos e quase
que a abrir um dos apartamentos e
parcerias lá como nós fizemos o ano
passado através da minha presença neste
caso é quase como abrir uma empresa nova
seção novos
a língua é diferentes modos de vida
diferentes a uma simples reunião que eu
estava habituado a quis que ela tá uma
hora numa reunião ia conseguir
ela falava de um assunto numa hora lá
fala em cinco minutos e tem que ser
assim e é muito legal que ser mais
objetivo importante é muito diferente é
comida é diferente também conta eu não
faço pausas pelo medo é uma espécie faz
primeiro um palco gigantesco importante
de tudo é muito é muito em frente à
escadaria perguntar-me ok então isso é
feita por alfinetes basicamente mexe eu
talvez sim talvez seja mas ainda há uma
pequena percentagem de casos em que isto
não é aceita por forlán se isto é a
receita para o sucesso
caso a pessoa tenha o veja encaro o
risco de uma maneira positiva o em
silicon valley trabalhamos muito isso o
risco é visto como uma oportunidade de
aprender não é visto como a sinônimo de
fãs
as novas idéias são vistas não de uma
maneira desconfiada eu sempre sonhei é
uma ideia completamente maluca casamento
ninguém irá dizer quais e de
comportamento parva não perguntam como é
que vai implementar
e depois de um ou dois anos ou 12 meses
eu e vou perceber o que realmente era
muito barba mas é aumentar este ano a
junta aqui uma malga nas culturas e
modos de vida e perspectivas que é muito
muito interessantes para o nosso produto
poder cheiro a poder escalar e acima
tudo nunca esquecendo o nosso produto só
podem mais longe se nós tivermos pessoas
caíram aliar a nós como estas marcas
depois falar e r 5 estava a fazer
o paralelismo com a minha experiência a
ou seja é minha empresa está a passar
por uma fase em que mais uma vez se
aceita o risco como oportunidade e isso
aconteceu na vida pessoal também
eu há dois anos em maio se ir para são
francisco cliente a um mestrado em
marketing internacional e assim o fiz e
foi um caso um dia para o outro foi eu
eu não sabia mãe que queria mas seria
mãe que não queria eu sabia que era
martin queria fazer mas eu estou em um
curso completamente congestionado com
filosofia e história portanto não tinha
nada a ver
e mais uma vez a receita para o falhanço
estava ali que é mais forçados unidos
não tem dinheiro não conhece ninguém vai
ser super longe pode não arranjar
trabalho pode não ter boas notas podem
tudo normal mas tudo pode correr bem e
portanto é tema ele como eu conhecia que
o que viria a ser o meu senhor foi super
interessante porque eu estava há dois
meses são francisco e de ir a um evento
de empresas portuguesas em silicon
valley é claro que eu estava estava à
procura um caminho de casa fora de casa
do campo - fosse um evento empresas ou
mais os caras não estaria tão ansiosa
para ir mas mas foi lá que eu a ouvir a
ideia do que era mas li neste caso
foi lá que eu realmente entra aí pois em
contato com o meu futuro disse hu e foi
aí que
é hoje em dia eu percebo que nós
estávamos naquele sítio por duas
entidades aqui eu ea empresa que
quisemos arriscar que não olharmos para
a que não olharmos para o risco como uma
maneira de com medo nós vemos uma
oportunidade e nós cremos silla
eu acho que isso é muito importante
passar principalmente na né
na conjuntura em que nós vivemos porque
isso é uma coisa que eu preciso e fico
muito triste quando chega a portugal é
que as pessoas se sentem um pouco
embaixo e eu só estava de sacanagem
dizer mas pode não é esse luiz neto pode
fazer mais isto pode fazer melhor que no
fundo queria passar é que não há limite
é natural é natural que haja perguntas é
natural
em termos pessoais e profissionais que
as pessoas duvidem se mas que a dúvida
não só aí já não seja motivos a pessoa
não poderá proibir não poderá ir mais
além e eu neste momento estou não posso
sentir que realizava com esta idade mas
posso dizer que estou a caminho e me
sentir realizado e isto porque
basicamente é isso que eu gostava de
partilhar convosco obrigada